well you have met so many people in this
country you've worked with a lot of
people in this industry so do you think
if we named just if we throw some random
names at you try me would you give us a
story okay I'm in a boost okay you're in
a booth okay okay well uh we go big here
so let's call this segment Henry's
Hollywood roulette
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so thank you Justin for the button
I'm gonna hit this button in whatever
name the roulette uh Wheels lands on
Henry has to tell a story about that
person if you if you haven't if I know
one okay okay here's here's the first
one here we go
[Applause]
Dolly Parton is not the queen of music
she is the Queen of the Universe I love
her and the kindest person ever okay so
I'm just beginning my directing career I
am chosen to direct her first television
movie A Smoky Mountain Christmas yeah
with nine children right yeah okay oh
that's so nice that two people saw him
okay anything
she was adorable she is powerful yeah
she is so smart and again plays 92
instruments so talented okay so I I
directed it and I and the head of NBC at
that time Brandon
um uh
thank you Brandon tartikoff came up to
me because our kids were the same
preschool and he said good morning 34
share which meant that we got a gigantic
share when it was aired on television of
the viewing audience and I I knew that
it was successful oh that
yeah I didn't know Brandon's name but I
knew that they didn't speak yeah do you
know what's funny though is everybody
describes you as the nicest guy in
Hollywood I think she is the nicest
woman in the industry she's probably the
kindest you run into so nice so filled
and like real like authentic and has
real conversations with you that aren't
like can do what she says she does yeah
absolutely I know
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]